they predicted it but they probably
couldn't believe it
pro-democracy wins across Hong Kong a
landslide against the establishment
through the night as they counted the
returns it was clear that the local
council elections had turned into a poll
on the government and its refusal to
deal with the millions who've taken to
the streets for six months I think that
the Hong Kong people should really
really leverage on this results to ask
for more democracy in the future
throughout the voting day establishment
candidates could see the writing on the
wall
infused protest party candidates were
posing for pictures pro-beijing
candidates next door were virtually
ignored and looked pretty glum the spin
from the government side is that the
local elections were unfairly
overshadowed by the demonstrations here
I don't think it would be appropriate to
look at this election as a referendum
because no specific topics have been put
forward for the voters to vote on and
what we have seen is purely
politicization of a la set of local
elections this really has been a record
making local election over seventy
percent of registered voters turned out
after waiting four hours in long queues
to vote for the first time all the 452
seats were contested in the end some of
the most well known government
supporting politicians were defeated by
young candidates with no political
experience whatsoever their unofficial
leaders are jubilant we already
expressed our political belief and our
determination and there's no reason for
Beijing ignore the more than two minutes
people vote in the election especially
most of the scene already won't by our
camp this beautiful city and its
territories have been rocked by six
months of protests and violence these
elections show the majority still
support the cause whether the government
and Beijing listen is a completely
different matter